l'usine des animaux un documentaire choc
qui nous décrit les horreurs que nous
faisons subir aux animaux d'élevage y
a-t-il un système organisé et criminel
est-ce exagéré de dire cela nous allons
en parler avec nos invités sur ce
plateau Daniel salmont bienvenue à vous
vous êtes sénateur écologiste dil Villen
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques vous faites partie des
parlementaires qui ont défendu le projet
de loi visant à lutter contre la
maltraitance animale loi adoptée je le
rappelle définitivement au Sénat le 30
novembre 2021 Yve Fantou bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes président de
culture viande premier syndicat
représentatif des entreprises françaises
de viande de boucherie et je précise que
vous dirigez la société famille Fantou
Corine Pelluchon bienvenue à vous
également philosophe professeur à
l'université Gustave Effel spécialiste
de philosophie politique et d'éthique
normative et appliqué vous avez publié
de très nombreux ouvrages he sur notre
rapport aux animaux je vais citer
manifeste animaliste politiser la cause
animale dans la collection rivage poche
petite bibliothèque et puis il y a votre
tout dernier livre l'espérance ou la
traversée de l'impossible chez
bibliothèque rivage Hugo Desnoyer
bienvenue à vous également bonsoir
artisan bouché à Paris vous avez deux
boutiques dans le 14e et le 16e
arrondissement et puis vous avez publié
ce livre recette de viande d'un partisan
bouché aux éditions First merci à tous
les quatre d'être ici je voudrais qu'on
reste quelques minutes si vous êtes
d'accord sur le constat sur les faits
tels qu'ils sont décrits dans le film
qu'on vient de voir Yve Fantou avez-vous
le sentiment comme cétait exprimé dans
le documentaire que nous voyons les
animaux comme des marchandises c'est le
point de vue du film est-ce que ce point
de vue vous
parle moi c'est un peu délicat enfin sur
ce que je vois parce que j'ai l'habitude
un petit peu de de décrypter un petit
peu ce qui peut se passer au niveau des
images pour moi j'ai l'impression d'ici
de de voir un film de propagande c'est
un monde qui correspond pas du tout au
mien euh je trouve pour résumer ma
pensée que il y a 175000 élevages en
France euh ça voudrait dire nous sommes
à peu près 500000 hein moi je représente
30 ou 40000 personnes 40000 personnes
dans le domaine de la viande ça veut
dire que personne se pose des questions
euh sur ce qu' fait euh qu'il y a aucun
aucun agriculteur ou aucun éleveur qui
est heureux et et finalement est est à
l'aise avec ce qu'il fait là je voilà je
moi j'étais plutôt effectivement choqué
par par les images certaines images bien
évidemment m'ont choqué mais ce qui me
gêne surtout c'est que c'est pas du tout
représentatif c'est c'est quelque chose
qui est très très orienté Daniel salmon
le regard de la réalisatrice et très
sombre he c'est vrai que c'est avec un
partiprix très fort tout fait est-ce que
ça vous parle vous au contraire euh tout
à fait bon c'est vraiment un
documentaire qui qui nous secoue euh on
a tous plus ou moins conscience que il y
a une certaine maltraitance animale on
parle souvent de la maltraitance animale
pour les animaux du quotidien qui sont
plutôt nos compagnons de route que sont
les chiens et les chats mais on on
oublie souvent cette maltraitance
animale auprès de tous les animaux
d'élevage et là vraiment on a un
documentaire qui qui met le doigt là où
ça fait mal et on peut se poser la
question comment en est-on arriver là
alors bien entendu j'entends bien ce que
ce que dit Monsieur Fantou euh moi c'est
pas du tout à travers ce documentaire il
s'agit surtout pas d'avoir une
condamnation de l'élevage en France et
encore moins des agriculteurs éleveurs
mais il y a une évolution dans notre
société qui nous amène à ce que l'on
voit aujourd'hui qui est sans sans doute
pas complètement représentatif de ce qui
se passe parce que je pense que les
éleveurs restent humains quelque part
mais il y a un système aujourd'hui qui
broie les hommes et qui broie les
animaux au propre com figuré pour les
animaux
et je pense que vraiment à travers ce
documentaire on doit
réinterroger notre rapport au vivant
et d'une manière plus prosaïque nos
régimes alimentaires comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui on mange autant de viande
et qu'on a multiplié par deux depuis
1950 la consommation de viande on le
voit bien à la fin de du documentaire
quand on parle de l'Asie du Sud-Est
enfin de l'Asie d'une manière générale
des populations des civilisations qui
ont été sur le végétarien et qui
arrivent à consommer énormément de
viande aujourd'hui on pourra en parler
je pense que c'est un vrai sujet moi je
suis flexitarien je mange de la viande
après tout est je pense aussi dans la
mesure est-ce que c'est à chaque repas
14 fois par semaine ou euh on en parlera
de la responsabilité supposée ou réelle
he du consommateur évidemment dans dans
une autre partie de cette émission mais
restons sur cette idée ce constat qui
est fait dans dans le film Hugo Desnoyer
la réalisatrice parle d'animaux comme de
la matière à transformer est-ce ainsi
que nous voyons aujourd'hui les animaux
d'levage moi bon bien sûr que le
reportage est choquant mais moi ce qui
me ce qui m'interpelle le plus c'est que
j'ai l'impression vraiment que on a
perdu la bataille des gens comme Mons
Fantou ou moi qui faisant un travail
complètement différent
et qu' fais travail en tant que boucher
artisan les éleveurs avec qui on
travaille moi j'ai pris une claque ça
fait mal ce que je viens de voir il y a
des choses que je connaissais mais la
Chine tout ça le développement les pays
justement oui comme vous dites
végétariens qui qui se mettent à à
manger de la viande pouro'est-ce que ça
vous en vous en tant que boucher
qu'est-ce GLOR de la France c'est TR
glorieux de la France on a explosé moi
j'ai grandi c'était la viande midi et
soir à table et chaque pays qui commence
à se développer malheureusement ça passe
par ça mais je crois qu'on a perdu la
bataille on a vraiment perdu la bataille
ça donc des gens comme nous on est
encore le on a encore le le côté
respectueux et on a la belle image de ce
qu'on doit faire et ce qu'on peut faire
mes éleveurs on le voit avec les proutau
avec leur maréchine en Vendé quel quel
qu reversement de situation et bien
bravo à eux parce que ils étaient très
très malheureux c'est ce qu'on on en
ressent oui on va les entendre mais euh
ouais bon déjà je suis dans le vrai je
pense nous sommes dans le vrai c'est
important à dire mais je suis très
secoué parce que je viens voir Corine
Pelluchon comment essayer de trouver un
équilibre entre ce film jugé comme étant
de la propagande par Monsieur Fantou et
en même temps qu'il dit une réalité avec
des chiffres incroyables 80 % des
animaux passent leur vie enfermés dans
des usine nous abattons 70 milliards
d'animaux chaque année tout cela est
juste j'imagine bah c'est-à-dire que je
trouve ce film est très fort parce qu'il
part du point de vue d'un couple
d'éleveurs qui se demande comment ils
ont pu accepter inacceptable comment
acceptons comment une société accepte
l'inacceptable alors bien sûr he vous
incarnez une un autre modèle mais cet
inacceptable existe et peut-on et
doit-on faire le lien entre justement
cette banalisation d'une violence
extrême envers des aides qui ne sont pas
vus comme des individus et à l'égard
desquels desquels tout est possible et
ce lien entre cela cette banalisation de
la souffrance extrême et une
indifférence morale un effondrement du
sens moral qui va nous habituer à
l'inacceptable dans tous les domaines
donc je crois que la maltraitance
animale est très importante en elle-même
mais elle est un coup de projecteur sur
cette indifférence moral qui gagne les
sociétés entières les sociétés
industrielles et je trouve que c'est
bien de se demander ce qui peut conduire
des individus à ne plus voir ce qui est
vraiment monstrueux pour vous le constat
la réalisatrice du fait que nous voyons
les animaux comme des choses comme des
objets est vrai vous le partagez ce
point alors je crois que c'est un
diagnostic qui s'est fait dans les
années 30 de grand philosophe de l'École
de Francfort avait pointé cette espèce
de
d'irrationalité rationnelle ou de
rationalité irrationnelle qui gagnait
les sociétés industrielles et qui qui
menaient au fascisme à la quantification
de tout à la réification de tout des
animaux mais aussi des humains je ne
mets pas je fais pas d'amalgame mais
n'empêche qu'il faut voir un petit peu
ce qui travaille en profondeur et la
société et c'est vrai que quand on voit
plus l'individu tout est possible h euh
à condition qu'on soit pas vu he qu'on
soit pas
pénalement condamné mais tout est
possible et il y a pas de limite est-ce
qu'on voit ces immeubles en Chine qui
sont une sorte de d'exemple d'un
capitalisme devenu monstrueux bah c'est
vraiment c'est incroyable pour les
animaux mais également pour les
personnes qui sont comme ça qui restent
une semaine et cetera donc on peut pas
accepter on peut pas dire voilà il faut
plus d'empathie parce que l'empathie
combattra le mal qui vient et on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il est là le mal absolu
revient c'est-à-dire l'emploi de moyens
illimité pour imposer son point de vue
c'est ça le mal la démocratie c'est la
proportionnalité des moyens la sagesse
c'est la proportionnalité des moyens on
n'est pas d'accord entre nous mais on
peut viser ça bon ben pour prévenir cela
je pense qu'on pourra pas faire de cours
d'empathie à l'école ou diffuser plus
d'humanité si on ne regarde pas en face
ce que nous faisons à des êtres que
personne aujourd'hui ne songe à comparer
à des machines donc il faut arrêter ce
que l'on a laissé faire ce film nous
décrit un système qui fait souffrir
l'animal mais vous l'avez déjà un petit
peu dit qui fait souffrir aussi les
êtres humains réécoutons en quelques
secondes si vous voulez bien cette
éleveuse qui nous raconte l'orreur des
scènes de castration auxquel elle s'est
livrée elle-même et je vous donne la
parole
ensuiteantou on castre on castre on
castre et puis on est tellement dans
notre truc machinal que P on castre à un
moment il y a il y a une hernie donc
c'est les boyaux qui ressortte et là ben
clairement ben le porcelet est condamné
elle est donc là tac on assomme le
porcelet puis on continue on repasse à
la suite on castre en castre on castre
et en fait on on n fait pas qu' quoi
c'est c'est comme ça bah oui on s'est
raté bon bah voilà merci au revoir et on
continue bah c'est c'est un produit et
quand on en a plus besoin bah on le
jette c'était carrément ça moi j'ai mis
des cochons à la poubelle comme comme
comme du plastique voilà on produit on
jette et et on recommence on reproduit
on jette c'est reparti il fant tout
avez-vous connu ou connaissez-vous des
éleveurs en souffrance comme comme cette
femme ou j'ai connu en tout cas la
castration à vif mais elle est interdite
he de maintenant depuis depuis quelques
années je je je peux connaître des des
des des éleveurs qui qui peuvent être en
souffrance donc là on a vu effectivement
ils étaient sur du port il y a eu un
échec sur le port ils sont partis ils
ont ils sont partis sur le bovin avec
une petite racee que je trouve plutôt
plutôt sympa quand je voyais des battes
dans le reportage
euh c'est impression d'être un humain
déshumanisé quand il fait son métier
est-ce que vous l'entendezch oui oui
mais je je trouve que là vous vous
parliez tout à l'heure m pchon de de de
de l'inacceptable moi je je je peux pas
penser que nos éleveurs acceptent
l'inacceptable chez nous en France je
connais des paquets d'éleveurs et qui
sont à l'aise avec ce qu'ils font quoi
l'important c'est ça et avec des gens
qui sont conscients bien évidemment de
la bien traitance qui qui sont
conscients de tout ça dans tout ce qu'on
a autour de nous on on va en parler tout
à l'heure mais vous on a vu là ici
l'apparition de multinational il y a
aucune de ces multination nation ici
présente en France aujourd'hui même nos
éleveurs sont sont regroupés en
groupement de producteurs ou en
coopérative et c'est eux qui dessinent
c'est eux qui décident donc on n' pas ce
polà de la société autour de ça donc
voilà moi ce que ce que ce que je pense
et et et se dire que ces gens-l enfin
que tous là on est complètement
inconscient de ce qui peut se passer je
trouve que c'est un peu nous insulter
quoi pas vraiment parce qu'il y le dénie
regardez elle dit bien on a accepté ça
on le voyait pas on fonctionnait comme
des machines alors je j'accuse pas vos
éleveurs en France mais de manière
générale ce n'est pas une émission pour
jeter l' sur les il faut surtout pas le
prendre comm faut traverser l'autre côté
du miroir c'est très important à un
moment le le le le Olivier il s'appelle
l'éleveur il pleure en fermant la le le
le hangar où ils étaient il a dit mais
comment j'ai pu faire ça hein nos no nos
petits enfants ou les petits enfants de
nos petits enfants nous accuseront
d'avoir laissé faire une société qui de
toute façon ça va nous envoyer dans le
mur au niveau sanitaire environnemental
et même les petits éleveurs que vous
représenter si ce système se
maintient les il faut vraiment une
réponse
politique voilà donc je vous passe la
parole il y a vraiment un système qui
est derrière vous parliez de de
conscience je pense que beaucoup
d'élever sont dans une semi-conscience
c'est bien c'est bien ce qu'on découvre
dans ce reportage là parce qu'il y a une
plasticité de notre cerveau qui est lui
donne la faculté de s'adapter à une
multitude de choses et de de
configuration et là petit à petit il y a
un glissement qui s'est fait et dans
l'esprit de ces agriculteurs de ces
éleveurs et bien il y a une telle
pression ils l'ont dit quand même à
nombreuses réises c'est parce qu'ils ont
l'air
de on a un film qui est très orienté
aujourd'hui ce ce filml est très orienté
vous voyez bien que c'est pas la réalité
de de ce que vous avez vous connaissez
sûrement des éleveurs en Bretagne vous
voyez bien quand même que c'est pas la
réalité de nos éleveurs j'en connais un
certain nombre mais vous le savez
également euh le taux de suicide chez
les agriculteurs est très très important
il y a quand même alors on peut le nier
mais il y a quand même un énorme un
énorme malêtre dans la profession
agricole qui est lié à des cours très
fluctuants euh de de produits agricoles
et qui fait que pris dans un engrenage
et mais vous dites c'est pas forcément
tout le temps aux Amériques hein que ça
se passe ça se passe également chez nous
les gens qui sont pris dans une espèce
de tenaille avec des endettements qui
sont là avec une course à
l'agrandissement et qui les font et bien
survivre au quotidien à un moment et
bien c'est bien ce qu'il dit on oublie
que cette cet animal c'est vraiment un
être sensible et on lui met un grand
coup de pied au derrière ou même un coup
de tournevis c'est ce qu'on voit dans
cette dans dans ce documentaire là et je
pense que Bonan Malan c'est des choses
qui peuvent arriver à tout éleveur Hugo
nen on en vient même à parler
aujourd'hui de crime contre l'animalité
en parallèle avec le crime contre
l'humanité est-ce que ça vous semble
exagéré est-ce que c'est un parallèle
douteux non c'est pas un parallèle
douteux c'est une triste réalité après
moi je dis toujours jour que nous sommes
tous éleveurs par procuration
c'est-à-dire que les politiques vous les
premiers vous devriez
imposer je crois que c'est en 2025 la
loi sur les restaurateurs qui font
eux-mêmes leur avec des produits frais
leur cuisine en 2025 seulement ça sera
obligatoire d'afficher ça dans les
restaurateurs marcons comment sont
élevés les animaux de façon claire vous
attendez plus des responsables
politiques dans ce domain là oui parce
que notamment là quand je vois la
Bretagne aucune attaque personnelle mais
quand je vois le développement qui qui
s'est passé dans les 30 dernières années
au niveau des cochons en Bretagne et
puis tout ce qui on découle au niveau
écologique les algues vertes et compagni
enfin c'est un truc de on marche sur la
tête quoi et on est en France
malheureusement on est en France mais je
voudrais dire aussi que la Commission
européenne avait promis de prendre à
brasle corp la question des des cages
puisque il y avait vraiment un mouvement
citoyen et actuellement il recule donc
du coup je pense que c'est vraiment oui
mais à cause des lobis bien sûr donc je
crois que sans arriver à gagner sur tous
les les les tableaux on peut arriver à
se mettre d'accord sur l'inacceptable et
à améliorer les conditions au moins de
détention et de mise à mort des animaux
dans toute l'Europe parce que et et ça
ça demande aussi un effort de la part
des consommateurs qui ne peuvent pas
avoir de la la viande comme ça tous les
jours bon bon marché et il y a toute une
éducation à faire aussi pour euh végé
l'imentation j'entends les mots lobby et
lobbying aussi Daniel salmon est-ce que
c'est vrai que c'est un secteur qui qui
fait aussi le forcing notamment sur les
responsablebl politique pour éviter au
niveau européen comme au niveau français
d'ailleurs de prendre des lois qui
iraient contre leur leur pratique ah
benah très certainement on le voit bien
t tous les jours tous les jours au Sénat
où il y a des filières des représentants
des filières qui qui sont présents
certainement il y a un poids économique
qui est considérable et en Bretagne
encore plus qu'ailleurs on le sait très
bien donc effectivement il va falloir
aller vers une transition on peut pas
tout balayer d'un rever de main mais il
faut prendre conscience de cette affaire
là alors le maître B aussi dans ce
documentaire que je trouve très
intéressant c'est l'invisibil
invisibil ben
invisibilisation on les rend invisible
he ris et euh donc il y a vraiment ça et
euh l'homme s'est déconnecté
complètement de l'animal et on lui offre
des filets on lui offre des côtes on lui
offre il ne voit plus on voit plus
l'animal qui est derrière et puis sinon
qu'est-ce qui nous mène là euh
effectivement on l'a bien vu euh dans
dans ce dans ce documentaire c'est quand
même un système qui cherche la
production la productivité au maximum et
la productivité il il y a vraiment
quelque chose moi qui m'a qui m'a
impressionné c'est la génétique aussi
comment est-ce qu'on a remodelé ces
animaux pour en faire euh ben des des
bêtes des bêtes pour la production des
machines à production on le voit bien
avec euh la vache pour le lait et qu'on
noblige à rester couché pour gagner 2 l
de lait on le voit bien avec ces Tru qui
sont enfermé dans des cages et on a
toujours sélectionné pour un maximum de
porceleil je pense que depuis le
néolithique depuis qu'on a inventé
l'agriculture on est allé dans cette
sélection animale très clairement donc
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui simplement ce
que l'on voit là c'est une accélération
complètement je dirais démentielle
depuis les 30 dernières ou 40 dernières
années on a toujours fait de la
génétique enfin depuis depuis le départ
même mes grands-parents enfin Mme
surtout qui ét éleveur de vin savoir un
petit peu donc là il y a dans le film un
chercheur d'ailleurs ce que je regrette
c'est que dans dans ce reportage enfin
dans ce documentaire euh on n aucun
vétérinaire qui soit aucun éleveur qui
soit un éleveur conventionnel qui sont
interrogés quoi bon c'est quand même les
vétérinaires c'est quand même des gens
qui connaissent quoi c'est des gens qui
sont à côté de nous tous les jours là
personne enfin on leur donne pas la
parole parce que il y a des choses qui
sont oui mais oui mais voonilà mais et
celui qui a fait de la recherche donc
justement pour essayer donc le gars il a
il a fait de la recherche justement sur
pour pour avoir des jumeaux notamment
chez bovin
5 c'est
ré là je vais vous dire très très
sincèrement je vous vous souvenez de la
vachestein là qui marche un petit peu
qui est filmé derrière Norman jein Baker
vous avez là enfin sur les images ici
qu'on a autour je sais pas si si si vous
voulez voyez mais vous avez une vache
qui a exactement la même mamelle et qui
a exactement le même profil voilà donc
ça dépend également de sous quel angle
on travaille ces chosesl c'estàd que la
vache qui se trouve dans ce CHL on ne
parle pas d'elle comme de celle qu'on a
vu parler donc ça roit la responsabilité
de l'éleveur
non non non non non non je veux dire
qu'il y a pas de catastrophe pour moi il
y a pas de catastrophe autour de ça et
ça dépend quel angle on donne aux choses
moi je pense qu'il y a une catastrophe
je suis allé je je m'excuse de vous
couper mais je suis allé au Space et moi
je suis choqué parce que moi j'ai connu
dans mon enfance les vaches normandes
qui avaient de la chair et qui donnait
du lait aujourd'hui on a fait une hyper
spécialisation et aujourd'hui dans a des
hstein qui ont les côtes les on a
l'impression que les os vont percer la
peau c'est complètement hallucinant là
où on est rendu aujourd'hui et j'ai vu
également ce sont des choix de
producteurs ce sont des ch d'élevage qui
qui ont tourné finalement la Normande
vers le lait et moi aussi he donc je
suis au bord du Cenon du bon côté du
Cenon mais je suis au bord du Cenon donc
je connais bien de l'autre côté
effectivement on la normande qui était
une race une vraie race mixte on est
parti plutôt vers le laitier j'espère
que ça va revenir il faut voir aussi y a
l'exagération bien sûr sur la modernité
des éleveurs aujourd'hui bien évidemment
que c'est pas la même modernité que dans
les années 60 ou 70 et que ça fait 20 ou
30 ans qu'on a pris conscience des excès
qui avaient pu se produire juste cette
question jusqu'à quel point l'animal
souffre il c'est une question aussi
importante et d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il
faut parler de douleur ou de souffrance
animale on a quelle différence entre les
deux on a une intervenante dans le film
qui fait le distingo je voudrais qu'on
l'écoute avant de d'y revenir ensemble
on a réduit la souffrance des animaux à
la question de la douleur la douleur bah
c'est de la biologie ça se mesure enfin
plus ou moins la souffrance est
subjectif on peut souffrir sans éprouver
de douleur voilà c'est c'est deux choses
différentes la souffrance c'est c'est
c'est lié au rapport au monde quoi et
donc oui les animaux ils souffrent de ne
pas
exister Corine péduchon c'est c'est une
une question compliquée est-ce que un
animal souffre au sens psychique au sens
psychologique du terme on a une scène à
un moment donné avec des cochons qui
semble-t-il sont tellement déprimé qu'il
ne mangent plus alors on les stimule
comprenez on les tape pour qu'il Mang
est-ce qu'il y a une un sujet de déprime
de dépression chez l'animal oui je pense
que d'ailleurs les éleveurs le savent la
la souffrance c'est un contenu psychique
ça peut être ennui c'est le stress c'est
la peur l'effroid la douleur c'est plus
biologique mais je crois que là personne
aujourd'hui ne songerait à n'imaginerit
prétendre que l'animal ne souffre pas
parce que c'est un être individuel il
n'a pas une conscience
représentationnelle comme nous il ne se
voit pas vivre il n'est pas de droite ni
de gauche mais il a euh il a il vit sa
vie à la première personne pour lui sa
vie est aussi importante que la nottre
l' pour nous donc la souffrance existe
et elle est elle est visible euh elle
est les éleveurs qui ont un rapport
charnel aux animaux qui sont à côté le
le save donc ils n'ont même pas besoin
d'Ur philosophes pour le dire ce qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui vous
nous dites aujourd'hui il faut pas des
gros élevages malheureusement ça devient
très compliqué pour les éleveurs parce
que un éleveur c'est 24 he/ 24 on a vu
le cas de poncorfe chez nous avec des
gens qui veulent s'occuper qui font un
refuge d'un zoau et qui finalement qui
est fermé par les services vétérinaires
derrière mais à mon avis parce que c'est
un vrai métier d'élever des animaux et
et c'est énormément de présence donc ce
que vont chercher à faire les éleveurs
dans quelques années c'est de
s'organiser et donc forcément peut-être
un peu plus de concentration animale
parce que on va se mettre mal non mais
c'est c'est c'est pas parce que alors
c'est pas parce que c'est un petit
élevage que c'est un bon élevage c'est
pas parce que c'est un gros élevage que
c'est un mauvais élevage des choses très
simples c'est pas parce que c'est un
petit producteur ou un petit abattoir
que c'est un bon outil et c'est pas
parce que c'est un gros que c'est un
mauvais donc des choses aussi simples
que ça donc réfléchissons vous me
demandez aussi de de de réfléchir je
vous écoute mais je pense qu'il y a des
choses aussi à voir autour de tout ça
desanis qui puiss faireon
puisseijeter et pour les élurs sejeter
aujourd'hui on a uneulté on a une
décapitation terrible que ce soit en
port en bovin même en lait chez nous
avec une baisse énorme de la production
la consommation ne ba pas ce qui fait
qu'on augmente de plus en plus nos
importations qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
rapport à tout ça parce que sur les
importations qui arrivent on a beaucoup
moins d're mot à dire que ce qui est
fait chez nous et que ce qui est fait
dans nos élevages
oui si on tenait compte des externalités
négatives si on tenait compte du cou
environnemental de l'élevage industriel
et du transport on aurait un juste prix
donc là aussi a une question je crois
une réflexion politique qui engagerait
un examen des prix et de de faire un
protectionnisme à l'égard de la viande
qui vient de loin qui est issu des élev
payer davantage les paysans de manière
générale qui ont aussi un rapport au au
l'écosystème et cetera voir les éleveurs
et arriver à cela bon moi moi je suis
pour une drastique de la consommation du
mais je pense que aujourd'hui au cette
question de la
consommation protéger les les élevages
dit plus extensif Daniel salmon je
rappelle ce que dit la loi française loi
du 10 juillet 1976 relative à la
protection de la nature qui fonde la
politique de protection des animaux
l'article 9 nous dit ceci tout animal
étant un être sensible doit être placé
par son propriétaire dans des conditions
compatibles avec les impératifs
biologiques de son espèce il est clair
que la loi
française interdit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les élevages tout à
fait c'est l'article L214 d'où le nom de
l'association qui montre bien que
l'animal est un être sensible et ce qui
est assez paradoxal vous en parliez tout
à l'heure mais au fur et à mesure où les
études scientifiques nous montrent que
l'animal est un être sensible et sur
bien des plans pas si éloignés que ça de
nous ça on le constate de plus en plus
même sur le plan émotionnel des choses
qu'on nimaginait pas hier même comme la
la jalousie des choses comme ça qui
peuvent alors faut-il faire évoluer la
loi Dan et bien il faut certainement
continuer de de la faire évoluer mais là
je dirais que vous parliez du marché
mais on va y revenir sur la consommation
mais on peut faire évoluer la loi de
toute façon vous interpellez pas mal les
politiques
que je je suis ravi mais moi je suis du
groupe écologiste nous sommes 17 sur 348
au Sénat je pense que on pousse on
pousse ces questionnements là mais en
face est-ce que vous trouvez des
oreilles atten est-ce que c'est
compliqué est-ce qu'il y a un dénis
est-ce qu'il y a une envie de ne pas
voir de ne pas savoir je pense que si on
montre ce reportage là effectivement ça
secoue mais derrière il y a comme dans
tous les autres pans de la société il y
a ce souci de vouloir faire fonctionner
l'entreprise de voir ça d'un d'un côté
macro-économique et on oublie on oublie
la mécanique de l'affaire et bien
entendu ça peut pas ce que je disais se
faire du jour au lendemain mais il faut
aller très rapidement vers une
transition parce que vous parliez des
externalités négatives on pourrait on y
reviendra peut-être sur les coûts réels
le coût réel de l'évage intensif
aujourd'hui on va sur la productivité et
le coût le plus bas il faut se rendre
compte mais on y viendra peut-être tout
à l'heure sur ça fait beaucoup de choses
je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive à tout dire
mais ou mais sur le fait que le panier
alimentaire a quand même baissé le coût
du panier alimentaire a énorm énormément
baissé même si en ce moment il y a quand
même avec problématique PIR d' mais ça a
baissé énormément et qu'on va toujours
vers le moindre coût et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on en arrive à essayer de faire
ces animaux qui deviennent une vraie une
vraie juste de la matière première sour
de rentabilitéo c'est une source de
rentabilité et derrière l'agriculteur on
l'a vu lui touche à peine des divid il
est on lui on lui maintient juste la
tête au-dessus de l'eau pour éviter
qu'il se doit parce que c'est lui qui
fait tourner il est question de quatre
grands groupes dans le film JBS Fribois
cargil Tyson Foods et WH group ils ne
sont pas en France ils ne sont pas ils
n'écrasent pas le marché Françis il y a
un de ceux qui est représenté en France
qui a profit qui achète de de de la
viande tout simplement et qui
approvisionne des chaînes de restaurants
voilà mais
c'est il y a aucun éleveur qui leur vend
un bovin ou un une voilà il y a ces
groupes là il y en a aucun donc c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça je trouve que le
le le film est quand même très réducteur
quoi par rapport à ce que par rapport à
ce qui se
passe la question là à mon avis la
question qu'il faut qu'on qu'on se pose
c'est Atton vous êtes d'accord je pense
euh tous les cinq j'espère avec moi
a-t-on le droit d'élever des animaux
pour s'en nourrir la question est
celle-ci il y a des gens qui pensent que
non et j'accepte qu'on pense que non euh
et dans ces cas-là ces gensl sont végan
et je les accepte enfin il y a aucun
problème c'est c'est leur choix eux de
l'autre côté euh si on accepte de
d'élever et d'abattre des animaux et
bien il faut aller jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire que on est tous un peu
éleveur on est tous un peu abatteur dès
qu'on est consommateur voilà moi moi je
reste très notamment sur les gens qui
qui qui qui font le geste de la de la
mise à mort je suis à leur côté jeis à
leur côté tous les jours voilà et je
trouve que c'est merci merci à eux voilà
alors parlons-en de cette consommation
euh que doit faire aujourd'hui le
consommateur doit-il se poser des
questions lorsqu'il achète notamment de
la viande dans un supermarché sousvide
en se demandant d'où elle vient et
comment l'animal a été traité avant rien
n marqué doit comment rien n'est marqué
rien n'est clair rien n explicite donc
il faut arrêter après le prix faut pas
faut pas se leurer quand vous avez une
barquette avec 10 bifte dedans et que ça
coûte 10 € déjà ça devrait vous et
est-ce qu'on peut demander à des parents
à des mères de famille lorsqu'elles font
leur cours et que tout est à disposition
dans les supermarchés de se poser cette
question là est-ce qu'on doit à ce
pointl problème de la guerre c'est
encore l'argent le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui la viande ça coûte vraiment
très cher c'est ça
la aujourd'hui quand même pour on a je
pense par exemple sur le steak haché on
a le steak haché le meilleur du monde
avec un steak haché peut-êre industriel
je suis désolé mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de nos avants
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de nos machins donc
le Stach est sans doute le meilleur du
monde avec un excellent produit par
rapport à tout ce qui fait où souvent il
y a des choses rajoutées là on est sur
du 100 % bœuf 100 % muscle la plupart du
temps et euh et on avait vu on a vu on
avait vu moins de prix bas euh ces
dernières années et là on est en train
de revenir finalement sur un peu une
guerre des prix mais ça c'est plutôt
c'est pas une Guer des prix chez nous
c'est une Guer des prix de distributeur
qui finalement en font un produit
d'appel et ont tendance malheureusement
souvent à tirer un petit peu vers le bas
mais le le le problème effectivement
aujourd'hui ce sera très difficile de
vendre déjà chez nous de la viande moins
chère vous disiez tout à l'heure et vous
acceptez effectivement de de payer plus
euh parce que c'est difficile il y a
personne qui s'en sort et aujourd'hui
notamment dans ma partie à moi c'est
c'est plutôt compliqué puisqu'on a une
décapitation on a une augmentation des
importations de l'autre côté on a aussi
des orientations qui sont différentes
notamment avec la volaille et là on a
des en consommation hors domicile on est
à enfin en consommation globale de
volaille on est à plus de 50 %
enimportation en consommation d'agneau
on en est là également on on est en
train de baisser on est en train de
baisser également un petit peu en bœuf
et les volumes perdus on les retrouve
pas derrière et donc on va les chercher
ce que vous disiez m pchon on va les
chercher ailleurs et donc on a beaucoup
moins de maîtrise c'est comme pour tout
le reste il faut que les centres de
décision restent chez nous Corine Puchon
mais moi je trouve quand même étonnant
qu'à une époque où on sait qu'il faut
manger moins de viande pour la santé
pour l'environnement il n'y ait pas un
mouvement plus d'imagination pour que de
la cantine à l'Élysée il y ait une
végétalisation comprends dans c'est
c'est pas seulement la viande ce sont
des produits
laitiersim vous avez raison vous avez
raison c'est aussi non mais çaet en
question complètement l'alimentation
française on parle de l'tage on parle
des yaourt on parle des fromages c'est
ça toutel mais nos grandsparents
mangaient moins de viande je veux dire
l'idée aussi nous avons été élevés comme
cela qu'il faut manger tous les jours de
la viande et que à cela il s'associe un
certain prestige he d'ailleurs voilà les
pays riches Eton ben oui mais
aujourd'hui ça change pour des raisons
sanitair ça doit changer parce que pour
des raisons sanitaires environnementales
à 8 milliards d'individus on peut pas
manger tous les jours de la viande c'est
pas possible et la seule réponse ce sera
l'intensification d'élevage intensif
donc si on veut aller contre
l'intensification de l'élevage intensif
qui est un mal absolu qui aussi a des
contreproductivités majeures sanitaire
environnemental et social et bien il
faut aussi aller dans ce mouvement de
transition chacun a son rythme en en
raison de sa culture et puis bon il y a
aussi les générations à venir ou les
générations prè plus jeunes qui
s'intéressent à ce que nous faisons des
animaux tous les jours je crois que il y
a finalement les philosophes c'est aussi
ça c'est avoir un temps d'avance c'est
accompagner un mouvement et regarder
l'avenir quel avenir on veut construire
bon et ben moi je pense que il faudrait
que les chefs cuisiniers fassent un
petit effort ou dans les cantine ou à
l'hôpital pour végétaliser
l'alimentation pour l'instant il y aura
toujours des gens qui mangeront de la
viande ils ont le droit mais voilà aller
vers ce mouvement or ce qui est très
étonnant c'est qu'on se crispe sur des
oppositions et et on avance pas avec des
techniques de
publicitaire très intéressantes dans le
film suicide food où on montre un animal
content d'aller à
l'abattoireable ce qui pass et pourtant
on est tous le public et la victime
Daniel salmon oui mais c'est il faut
aller vers un avenir sans viande sans
produit laitiers non mais c'est une
révolution culturelle tout ce qui s'est
construit on l'a vu au cours des 5
dernières décennies on va dire où on a
symbolisé la réussite sociale par manger
plus de viande plus de produits laitiers
aussi ça commen d'ailleurs au Pays-Bas
et aujourd'hui il faut réinterger tout
cela parce que l'élevage c'est 14 % des
gaz à effet de serre mine de rien ça
pèse énormément et il faut réapprendre
sans doute la lenteur quelque part la
cuisine parce qu'aujourd'hui tout ça
vient d'un marché on a essayé de faire
tout faire rentrer dans le marché et
tout ce qui se faisait à l'intérieur du
foyer et bien on l' marchandisé et
aujourd'hui personne ne sait plus
assaisonner enfin cultiver des
légumineuses des pois des lentilles
toutes ces choseslà on a laissé tomber
tout ça pour faire de la facilité la
facilité c'est le plat préparé et c'est
la viande et ça il nous faut nous on
demande politiquement que on refasse des
cours de cuisine dans les écoles parce
qu'il faut se réapproprier la nourriture
la nourriture elle a été confisquée par
des multinationales par des industriels
et ça vraiment on a perdu complètement
not notre autonomie et notre argent
c'est pour ça que ça coûte très cher et
juste pour finir effectivement manger de
la viande oui mais de la bonne viande et
à son juste prix donc tout est entre les
mains du consommateur si je comprends
bien alors qu'il est un peu
déculpabilisé dans le documentaire là
pour le coup on y revient c'est entre
nos mains à tous plus qu'entre les mains
des éleves Mo je trouve ça grave et puis
c'est pour ça que je répète que le
combat est quelque part perdu vous
parlez de 8 milliards d'individus sur
Terre on voit le développement qu'il y a
en Chine quand même plus d'un une
personne sur deux en Asie qui qui qui
habite cette planète et ça explose on en
fait des HLM non bah bien sûr que non
ben le reportage le montre bien lui-même
moi je suis avec Monsieur Fantou on est
je sais pas 0 01 % avec nos éleveurs qui
sont qui sont rétribués payés au juste
prix de leur travail ils sont pas
subventionnés pour à peu près voir sorti
de l'eaulur ils gagnent leur vie avec
leur travail c'est quand même une
valorisation qui est hyper importante
maintenant le le client le consommateur
c'est lui qui décide c'est lui qui
décide de l'achat c'est lui qui décide
de ce qu'on fait juste une touche
d'optimis et ensuite ils font tout pour
conclure ce débat une touche
d'optimisme il y a 20 ans 30 ans quand
on défendait le vélo tout le monde nous
rayonnait que ça ne reviendrait jamais
et bien le le vélo il est là et il
suffit que on va dire les classes un peu
plus aisé aujourd'hui sont en train de
se détacher de la viande est ce qui
était le symbole de la réussite
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est les
classes les plus défavorisées qui
mangent le plus de viande et et petit à
petit voilà cet exemple là peut faire
bouger beaucoup les choses et moi
j'espère que ça va aller dans ce sens
une révolution est en marche il fantô
non enfin oui peut-être mais au global
moi ce ce que je souhaite aussi c'est
comme vous c'est qu'on revienne à la
cuisine et effectivement des choses
simples quand on voit les problèmes
d'obésité chez les gamins là aussi en
politique si moi j'ai quelque chose à
vous dire c'est mettez quatre REP
équilibrés à la cantine voilà c'est tout
ce qu'ils ont parce que c'est peut-être
les seul repas équilibré que vont avoir
certains gamins pendant la semaine donc
commençons par des choses avec des
choses aussi Simp que ça euh d'un are
côté aujourd'hui euh très sincèrement je
pense que et c'est pas moi qui le dis
mais des des des scientifiques qui
disent tout simplement se priver de la
viande c'est faire un saut dans le vide
et aujourd'hui on a besoin de de de
béquill pharmaceutique à côté donc c'est
Philippe lerand qu'on avait rencontré à
Renn m péuchon qui est chercheur à
lincne et euh voilà donc je pense qu'il
y a des des des choses à regarder
repassons effectivement repassons par
par la cuisine mais euh là aussi je je
reprendre un autre scientifique qui
disait simplement et là j'espère que je
je mettrai d'accord tout le monde manger
c'est bon pour la santé c'est bon pour
le moral et c'est bon pour le partage
voilà donc aussi simplifiant un petit
peu les choses s'arrêa sur ces mots
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cet échange merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi comme chaque
semaine documentaire et débat à
retrouver sur notre plateforme
publsenat.fr à très bientôt sur public
Senat
[Musique]
merci